les fait tous les métiers dans le cinéma
sur les personnages que vous jouez alors
j'en ai noté quelques-uns chez berthe où
vous êtes boxer chez truffaut est
instituteur ch et demi vous êtes
grévistes chez mots qui vous est flic
schémas sont vous êtes psychanalyste
chez rochas vous êtes un homme piégé
vous êtes frères grave et chez chez
ferré toujours plus tôt des écorchés
vifs toujours plus tôt des fous amoureux
qui sont bien tabasser par la vie ça
c'est des choix ou ceux des hasards ou c
c'est un prototype d'acteurs vous êtes
dangereux vraiment dans mon cas je crois
que ces deux-là hasard parce qu'il n'ya
pas y'a pas effectivement moi j'ai le
désavantage de ne pas avoir fait quand
j'en rêve j'en rêverai dans une
prochaine vie de fer conservatoire et
tout ça c'est à dire des vraiment acteur
le rêve enfin la vie rêvée ça serait de
pouvoir jouer comme acteur temps en
temps parce que c'est un vie très
violente c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
violent que ce que laisse jouer
alors en plus c'est des choses même un
film assez bons longs comme tournage la
tortue sur le dos et 8 semaines de
tournage par exemple bon là mais ça ne
dure que 8 semaines bondissant toussaint
une décharge à court terme et alors la
mise en scène enfin telle que je la
conçois moi c'est c'est vraiment la
traversée de l'atlantique à chaque fois
il y aller on sort et puis après il ya
les grandes vagues si vraiment on est
seul maître à bord etc etc
c'est simple parents fonctionnaires
petite ville de province études
c'est à dire et tu le semblant d'études
mais quand même grande école non dans ce
groupe paris paris cinémathèque et après
dans ce coup après avoir écrit 2002 qui
servent à rien concert jimi hendrix
olympia et là je rentre on dira que babu
rappeneau quatre jours après je suis
engagé sur un film comme stagiaire sur
un film d'alain cavalier
catherine deneuve si tu nous regardes
piccoli et là je sûrement stagiaires 15
avenue tolgoi je me rappelle absolument
pas dans la vie change et après on vous
dit après on vous dit mais c'est comme
un type qui est dans un petit garage au
fin fond de la sicile et il se retrouve
à changer le chez ferrari et ça ça
change jamais dans l'apd est circonspect
rahway non ça se gonfle jamais la tête
ce que vous dites toujours non c'est un
tel miracle d'abord une chance dans ce
soit 25 ans que la vie change et vous
offre une chance d'aller vers ce quoi
vous voulez aller qu'après c'est tout
c'est tout cas des cantons et des deux
côtés de la caméra la fois qu'est ce qui
se passe
alors là tout va bien bizarrement c'est
toi km l'énergie qui branchent les gens
tu amènes à l'etac tournage ça
s'organise le plan ce précise-t-il
invente au fur et à mesure sur des
vieilles idées tu avais des paquets dans
des poches des bouts de dialogue puis
finalement c'est comme si tu parlais à
deux boxeurs mais d'un seul coup c'est
toi qui boxe à la fois le manager que la
fois sur papier mais l'exemple d'une
passion leur imputation coutu commence à
tourner avec l'autre entre pilotes
rentrent dans le jeu et puis tu ne vas
quand même l'oeil pour savoir si la
caméra sont de 6 à suivre et puis d'un
seul coup il ya un truc alors là si les
trentenaires il ya un manque qu un site
non pas qu avec le film que tu voulais
faire mais tu es en train de le voir
alors moi j'ai eu des moments comme ça
effectivement dans passe montagne tu
sens la caméra tourne une pause histoire
est en train de se faire c'est à dire
les rapports entre les personnages c'est
en train de devenir vivent pas est ce
que vous pensez comme puisse faire du
bon cinéma avec peu de moyens à l'heure
actuelle le rêve ce raid c'est le vieux
temps d'aller woods on va pas recréer le
cinéma ils l'ont fait en 1930 les
studios mack sennett frank capra chaplin
on continue à parler de chaplin c'est
pas par hasard c'est parce qu'il a su
tout faire et justement avec des moyens
énormes et je veux dire c'est pas du
tout un handicap moi je rêverais d'avoir
des gens qu'on puisse payer normalement
ne pas être obligé de mégoter sans arrêt
d'implorer de supplier et cetera
[Musique]